what's up
good morning everybody welcome along to
this extraordinary meeting of the
performance policy and partnerships
committee uh welcome to those joining us
on live stream
uh today is about
hearing
uh the submitters who wished to be heard
you will have an opportunity after each
submitter has
completed
their presentation to ask questions the
questions are about their submission not
an opportunity to voice an opinion that
comes next week once we deliberate
um so your understanding as we go
through that process would be
appreciated
uh i've not been notified of any
counsellors joining us via zoom but i do
have apologies from both councillor
pottinger and councillor craic it would
simply like to move they are received
councillor lewis and councillor clark
i'll put that all in favor
against
carried
first item before we get into
hearing the submitters is to actually
receive the report hearings for the next
step for city block consultation
somebody care to move that these are all
the written submissions that you've got
counselor scout counselor arnold
any questions or comments
actually i should also um
include on that receive the submissions
made on the consultation which is agenda
items four and five
noting the summaries of submissions now
and also agreeing to receive the late
submissions received after five on
friday which was from a jessica and jill
howie so the mover and second are
comfortable with those being included as
well
yes and
looking out the door
counselor arnold you're okay with that
cool thank you i'll put that all in
favor
against carried thank you for that
right that brings us to the uh
submissions um
mr
gaddison you'd like to come up and
take a seat
is he
sorry
i'm sorry i can't say from here
no kidding that's why i've got mine off
mr peterson
is he here
right what about
is gear joining us via legs
right now um i know that you're
scheduled for uh
9 35 but are you comfortable
coming in early
as comfortable as you can be in the
riviera of the south
well it's hard to tell it's an
interesting background which one of you
should i look at
um
probably the one that's moving around
thanks for your submission old
councillors have had a chance to to have
a read through this is an opportunity
for you to speak to it and once you've
done that council has asked questions of
you yeah so i i would say kia ora and
good morning
to your worship um the chair
uh darren their uh councillors and staff
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak
and i've taken a great interest in the
development there because i've
seen similar developments um back in
town where i
grew up and where i lived and
i also noticed um a similar development
on rachael roar which
i think was the most successful of all
and i'll touch on that in a second
um and one thing that i noted
um in town and i make with this design
and like you know i went and had a look
at the design and spoke to the designers
was that
these outdoor settings are often
created and designed um
with the seating out in the weather it
might when you walk past
even at the moment with the seats in
town
and then the cable city and
when it's raining more the seats are wet
and you can't sit on them and there's
quite a lot of rain in in the cargo
um in the winter especially as we know
so and i i think it's actually perhaps a
strategy to
encourage people to go inside the shops
and particularly the you know the food
outlets and so forth
rather than sit on the chairs outside
come inside and sit in a shop
and
i i really think that um
as i've said in my submission that um we
should actually um put up some side
sales or
um you know have some shelter that um
people can actually be protected
not only from the rain but um when it
actually does get too hot
and machine sails could actually be
removable
um and put back and that's
in fact they could be automated
um and i i actually um when i spoke to
the
the designers um and looked at the
the uh design that they had proposed
i talked about having um some
covered
a covered glass area
with shade um as needed
you know and as i say movable and
an example of that is there's an arcade
in right of rua and i can see the
details on if you wish
um
it's particularly it's it's the same as
esque street and they've covered it with
a glass canopy
and it's um
very attractive for people to go there
all weather all year round and i
realized that that isn't in the current
budget but it
may well be something that we could
consider perhaps in the future
and uh and a little example of of the
same thing is the south city mall it's
only very small but when you walk in
through there
there's a very pleasant covered
walkway
um and there's that's your feed and set
up in there and
it would actually be um great for the
people that do provide um food and
entertainment and such like not to have
all the equipment down in the rain and
the weather
and it could be all year round
um another point that i thought with
that is that i really you know i don't
want to change the plantings that
they've got planned now but if we look
to the future we could perhaps put in
edible plants and i'm not just talking
about
putting in some silver meat and tomatoes
or so it's like i'm talking about
putting in some
shrubs and perennial shrubs and pyramid
shrubs and trees that have
um fruit on them all year round
and under a glass situation that would
be
a great idea that's what i think and and
i just see it more as a future direction
okay and then
just moving on to um and and i'm a big
fan of the you know the the architects
we came on what i was saying
and i'm a big fan of architectural
aluminium and plate glass and i think if
it's done properly over the last century
so no
can i just pause you for a second there
one yes but not specifically speaking
seeking feedback about design aspects
right uh it's it's about the the
financing options
okay well as you read um in my um
submission i actually agree with the
options that you put forward
but i understood that i was given the
opportunity to talk about
um the design here at this point in time
as well
there is um an element of
where we carry the streetscapes to but
not the specific design of it at this
point however i mean you've you've made
some some interesting points in your
written submission as well and we do
note those
thank you
can i just make two other points and
i've got time to say yeah
i think that we need
um
packing safe packing for you know
people's valuable
and bikes and cycles and e-cycles that's
like a charging point i've ridden my
bike in from bluff and the kaggle and
there's nowhere to charge it and i
actually had to buy a 700 battery so
that i knew i had a spare battery to go
back if i needed it
and that includes people with mobility
scooters
and uh and the other thing was i
i don't see any rubbish funds in the
design or recycling bins and
i was actually told at a recent meeting
here and there may be a move away from
even providing bills so
you know i i take that on board and but
let's let's see where he goes and and
finally i just like to comment that with
all the rubbish and
it was at your company in hamilton and
i've seen the details making a board
it's a new project called safe board
and any any place to get any junk that's
of no use and then turning it into a
good product so i'll leave it there and
thank you for the opportunity to
add the design comments as well as um i
folly as i say fully support
um the um the patriot options any
questions thanks and i'll appreciate
that questions for for now councillors
if there are none thanks noel for your
submission obviously it's a it's a
public meeting you're welcome to uh stay
and listen to the other submitters and
the rest of the meeting we will just
mute you though for this point thank you
very much for for your time this morning
councillor abbott welcome along
yes thanks uh we had a big problem
trying to get connected
thanks um
councillors that brings us to the second
submission which is uh mr thompson
melvika if we could just take him off
gear uh are you able to uh take yourself
off mute please
it could be a long wait
apologies for the delay counsellors will
just wait
see if we can get a message to mr
thompson
oh is that right yep that's it yeah
we've got a bit of technical assistance
now
i suppose so
yeah yeah here we go
videos on sounds all good good gear
thank you very much welcome along
sorry about that just needed a bit of
technical assistance yeah
no problem there's a lot of that going
around it's a whole new world
hey thank you very much for your
submission gear we appreciate it uh you
know the the process um with with the
hearings it's really over to you now to
to speak to it once you've done uh
counsellors will have some questions for
you
yes no thanks for the opportunity and um
but um you know this as you know has
concerned me for a long time this
project
and um i just feel the poor old
ratepayers
carrying the can and um
i don't think the council should have
actually been involved in the first
place because it's a speculative
commercial development
and should have been left to the private
sector to
to undertake
um
and
i don't think the rate payers have even
been given the true picture of
this situation
because the council has purposely kept
it as a
non-controlled
um
council
organization
and yet um they have consistently been
the bigger um financier or shareholder
and not the shareholder because they
were the smaller shareholder but
financier
in this project
and to my way i think even they should
have got very nervous when the
developers change the resource consent
from having the finance arranged to
being comfortable that they would have
uh get the finance
and um
it is
pretty obvious at that stage that the
finance was going to be difficult
and um
also um
if the council had done more homework on
these
malls and they would realize that this
one is a very expensive one
and likely to
well i i would like the councillors to
find out for their own comfort what the
end valuation will be um
compared with what the cost is now which
is getting up to 180 million
and plus the fact we've got all the
rating but
because just as a
an example um
the um
the time that they were looking at this
the pararoo mall had sold for a hundred
just over a hundred million at an eight
percent yield
and um is here the farmers it came kmart
lots of shops parking and office space
and
in recent times we've had the barrington
wall in christchurch sell for 65.5
million
at around a 7.5 yield
with the warehouse fresh choice
supermarket uh two large format shops 48
specialties eight office tenancies and
563
car parks
the palms and shirley in christchurch in
december last year sold for
88.8 million at an 8.5
return
with anchors of countdown farmers
eight screen reading cinema complex nine
large format tenancies 75 specialties
nine kiosks 80m a car wash and
1473
car packs and there's others i could
give you two but that just gives you an
example
about um
that these uh you know
i feel the council's been sold a pup
here
um
and
also
rate payers
um
now
into the debt of around around about 73
million with the shares and the loans
plus another
34.4 million for the street upgrade a
lot of which wouldn't have been
necessary had history not been dug up
and uh which was quite tidy and it had
been a lot of work done on a few
previous years as well
and i don't think it's fair to fear on
the ratepayers so for them being having
to carry the can
particularly those with nearby buildings
many of which may need earthquake
upgrading and they're likely to lose
their tenants
to this
excuse me to this more
so they're faced with added costs and no
income
and that that's
not at all helpful to them
and um
and to say that the loan of 22.5 million
is is not going to be a cost to the rate
payers is not
correct either
because
it'll be a cost to the rate payers in
the form of a lack of return from this
development because although the
development might be paying the interest
on the loan
it'll be a lot longer before they'll get
any return out of the development
because of this
added interest cost so it's not really
clear that
and um
the council is now the largest
shareholder in that at uh development at
45.8 per cent as i see that the
richardson group have reduced theirs and
the government are now a shareholder in
the in the thing as well
um
and i just believe that the other
parties should be taking their share of
the costs in this development rather
than the council being the one to have
to continually keep fronting for it
um i'm happy to answer any questions i
did you know you've got my written
submission if you want
anything else
thank you mr thompson councillors any
questions or
for mr thompson councillor clark
yeah gear and i'll be close
a couple of things that you've commented
on um one was the um
the landlords in the adjoining area who
have to deal with uh earthquake prime
building status
and doing remedial work there with
potentially no tenants but it's fair to
reflect that
that remedial work has a 20
a 20 year span doesn't it
so it's not something has to be done
tomorrow
and
yeah it depends i think on what street
they're on doesn't it if they're on a
prime street i think it has to be done
earlier doesn't it so my understanding
is the the wording is arterial
so i'm i'm picking an arterial road
around the coast would be uh spay
oh sorry would be um tay and
and um
the
and d not not uh not the uh the ones
that are joining so the purpose of the
material is for for emergency services
so that was one issue i guess i was just
wanting to clarify with you
and you know you're quite rightly
could i just say that i appreciate that
if the mechanical council doesn't put
too much pressure on these people for
that because
i think that is
certainly a great help you know because
if they've got more time
things you know they'll probably get
tenants and they've
because it's shortage of engineers and
construction people and everything else
and i think if the council adopt a
policy of being reasonable about that i
think that will be a great help yeah
sure
just to remind a counselor that we're
not here to reflect or rebut we're
asking questions
well i'll ask a question that's
excellent
so gear uh you'll be aware through the
consultation through the
deliberations that we did
that council took into account i guess a
social impact
um for the city uh where a pure investor
might just look at a yield and say well
there's not a good return or the future
is not good or we're over capitalized
you will be aware i guess that we took
into account that we wanted to
um
re-energize the cbd that over many
decades that cbd had splintered away to
other pockets around the city um
yeah um yeah i appreciate that i
appreciate that um undercover shopping
will also be
um you know popular uh particularly
winter
um
but it could have
probably been done in a
not as an er extensive manner
which um
is
added to the cost
enormously
it could have been a quite a nice
development done using cambridge arcade
in good shops or for either side of it
and
which would have kept a lot of the
character of the town as well
which in small
provincial towns i think a lot of that
character is starting to be appreciated
now
and i often refer to the difference
between likes of wanganui where they've
sort of
trying to keep the character and support
people doing um improvements on
character buildings
but um it is
depends you know
if you look at malls you look at likes
of queensgate
and what it did to the rest of the town
was that help to the town
uh no not really the rest of the lower
hut there became um
you know vacuum for a long time
and
same thing happens in hamilton with
the base and things that uh you've got
to be careful that
it doesn't suck the lifeblood out of the
rest of the town as well at the same
time which is
one of the concerns because there's no
good having just one hub and then the
rest of the town
looking deserted
which is what is a concern i have yeah
yeah thank you for that and just
appreciate the comments about the
character buildings because
looking closer to home to omarou you can
see where preservation of those
buildings has kept the character in the
in the city area
yes and it's made a tourist attraction
for omarou too
it's become quite a tourist attraction
because
so many other places
particularly you know even christchurch
you know with this earthquake there that
the um a lot of the character of new
zealand has been destroyed and
a lot of parts people go to england and
various parts to to look at the
character of places because it's been
there for centuries yeah
not a bad film set either
thank you gina that's a good film set
council has any other questions for mr
thompson
if not gear thank you uh for your
submission and for making yourself
available this morning to to speak to it
and to answer questions uh you're
welcome to stay for the rest of the
hearing we'll just um we'll place you on
mute from this end okay thanks for your
time this morning no thank you and
all the best thank you
dave uh we're running slightly ahead of
time i think uh
one of our submitters is now no longer
joining us so
welcome along thank you for your uh
submission on behalf of the invercargill
public art gallery
yes uh thanks very much for the
opportunity uh to speak um
so just like to make it clear uh before
i begin that
this is to ensure that there's no
conflict of interest for our ex-officio
board members um those council members
on our board this these are the
consensus views of our elected members
only so i just wanted to make that clear
at the beginning
um
[Music]
so our um collective
consensus view is that we
prefer
um
both of the preferred options that were
suggested in the
document
um so um this presentation is really to
support those uh preferred options but
also
just remind um the council of our
existence and a value that we can add to
that
city block development
um so i think i made a few we've got uh
six submission points um that i'll just
sort of expand on a little bit
um
so uh hey wakatuya
which is the gallery that um air
art gallery now has the
contract to manage
is kind of on the edge of the city block
development and but we feel that its
existence will attract visitors to the
city centre and support the project
and will add value to the experience of
the city block development
we also think that
as the
money is spent on the street development
that we would like to
have
considered of
how the kind of appearance of our
building
connects
with the whole development because
we found it extremely difficult to
operate when there was building work um
and construction work on the road area
it discouraged um pedestrians and
although i understand that in any
development that occurs but
when
the development actually goes ahead we'd
like to see
sort of enhanced street appeal and it
would be really good to have perhaps
sculptural works or um historical
elements um
outside the actual building
to kind of draw visitors in and have a
connection with the outside
and
one thing that we'd be keen to have is
um
bike stands outside a building
we understand that you're trying to
encourage active
forms of transport and to have bike
stands outside
the gallery
would be a really good advantage
and in terms of
the value that we can add as well
um we've got a very talented team who
have a lot of experience
in public art
and if there is going to be public art
in that area we'd like to be sort of
included in
um any of the planning and installations
that occur in the area i think we could
add value just as an example
of
the kind of things that we can do
you may remember and there used to be an
organization in the past called vibrant
invercargill
and they had a fund of money that was
left
when the organization was disbanded and
that was gifted to our gallery to use in
a way that we thought would be useful
for the community
and so we've actually um
commissioned
a young artist who was an indica person
but now living in australia who creates
kind of like neon art i think they use
lid lights now
but we've just taken the delivery off a
whole collection i think there's about
13 pieces of sort of iconic southland um
sort of icons
created out of this
lighted material
that's kind of portable where it could
actually be placed in different parts um
the city as well as our gallery so with
um
things like that i think we could add
value to any promotional stuff that's
happening in the in the city block
development
um
and
um we'd also if there's any promotional
material when the whole
development is completed
we'd like to be included in any of the
promotions because we think that
we add value to the development and it
will also attract people into the city
centre
i think that's probably me
thanks dave thank you for the submission
on behalf of uh ipeg and also drawing
our attention to the fact that the
effects of the city blocks spread a
little wider than just
um
the area it compasses and the flow on
effects to the surrounding streets and
the offer around um outdoor art i think
there's a few pieces that are currently
in storage that are probably looking
forward to reappearing as well
councillors any questions for mr kennedy
cool that's nice and succinct thanks
dave thank you very much for for putting
the submission in and for making
yourself available this morning
no problems at all
thanks a lot
councillors that brings us to the end of
submissions mr mcgaston has been in
touch and uh will not be joining us um
so
between now and next tuesday when we
deliberate again it's an opportunity to
refresh and re-read the written
submissions because obviously they form
part of the
final decision that we're making uh
claire or rhiannon any final comments
before i adjourn
um
i'm happy to rejoin the meeting mr chair
i was hoping i might get two minutes
with councillors thank you
uh if there's no further business then
we will be reconvening on tuesday
morning for deliberation and i will
adjourn the meeting and that will end
the stream thank you to those who have
joined
you